my presentation is going to be declined
generally set the scene and I'm going to
leave it to Etienne to talk about a lot
of the more technical details and how we
do some of our data science but I wanted
to start with with a much more sort of
general question of what is in the wolf
view what is what is data science and
what are we trying to do with that aids
science so give me a moment here and I
will show my screen here and save some
bandwidth for everyone by turning the
webcam off and I wanted to start by with
addressing really one thing that I've
heard repeatedly when I go and talk to
customers about data science which is
they end up they go out and they hire a
bunch of data scientists because they
feel like that's the new thing that
needs to be done but then when they look
back a little bit later they realize
that they're just paying a bit more
money to do the same old statistics that
they were doing before data science
became the in thing so it's data science
just a synonym for statistics well I'm
going to define it slightly differently
and it seems like a subtle difference
that data science is computation with
data but if you look at that from the
context of what we've been doing with
the Wolfram language for the last nearly
30 years computation is a really bored
subject it includes things like
classical statistics but it's also
things like machine learning which we'll
hear about from etienne in half an hour
and all kinds of other conversation like
geometry and image processing and
textual semantic analysis and audio and
and visualizations and simulations all
of these different things are
computation and with a little bit of
imagination they can all be applied to
data and to get insights from data which
in the end is what we're trying to do
with data science so if computation is
the big thing rather than rather than
statistic what's what's what does that
give you but classical statistics which
really centers around counting doesn't
give you well the first thing is it
gives you new things to count but you
can do statistics on new kinds of data
if you can pull that data out of out of
the underlying data in more interesting
ways so I brought few examples
unfortunately a lot of the work we do in
our technical services is under
nondisclosure so in bringing some work
for
some of my least paying customers
this first one comes from a little
project I did with my daughter she was
wanting to write an essay about Lord of
the Flies her favorite book and she
wanted to inject a bit of data science
into it to make it not just literary
analysis and she said well where do the
characters occur in the book so we did
this little piece of basic counting
where we looked at the character names
and where they occurred throughout the
book so from the beginning of the book
you get an early appearance of ralph who
takes the lead in the book warning here
I'm gonna spoil I've got a few spoilers
of the story here there's an early
appearance of the beast when they're
exploring the island but it doesn't
become significant until the middle of
the book which sort of precedes the rise
of Jack who uses fear of the beasts to
take control so that seemed like a
pretty satisfying results in terms of
counting but now's as far as pure
statistics seem to get us and it didn't
tell us anything about the tone of the
book and this was meant to be in English
literature essay not a maths essay so we
started talking about well what else
could we count and we started finding
thinking about things like applying some
basic machine learning to do things like
sentiment analysis on the sentences so
we went through the sentences one of the
time and says what what's the
probability that each of those sentences
is positive and we can use that as a
measure of the how positive the
sentiment sentences are and here's the
maximal I've just searched the entire
book just now as we were speaking and
found this sentence that's most likely
to be a positive sentence we're going to
have fun on this island which for those
of you read the book isn't really how it
pans out but once we have this new tool
we have something new to count and so we
went through using that as a new measure
and overlaid on top of the previous plot
this measure of the tone of the book and
in reveals can quite interesting human
insights that the Tonys quite negative
at the beginning they shipwrecked it's
really positive when they're having fun
exploring the island and then it goes a
bit neutral and then as the antagonist
takes power things go a bit negative
things pick up as our lead character
tries to regain control and then things
go rapidly downhill towards a rather
bleak into the book so then we have
something that that it's a new kind of
information that was in the words but it
wasn't the words that we were doing
statistics on
his a and you know when you think about
the different kinds of data every days
it comes with its own ontology of
computation so there are things like
sentiment that applies to text where
sentiment wouldn't apply very well to
geometry but things like shape and
curvature apply to geometry and if you
look at things like image processing we
can do exactly the same thing and say
let's find new ways to count what we see
by doing it by images so this was
another non-paying project that I did
this is my wife's work she's doing
needless injection systems so these are
particles of would be drug shot like a
shotgun through this layer of skin this
is actually a a sort of fake proxy for
skin but then what she needs to count
how deep did the particles go and how
clustered are they and if they're too
dense it does damage to the skin if
they're not going deep enough that God
doesn't get delivered so that's pure
statistics but we have to get to the
point where we can count things so I
looked at the problem and thought well
we've got these blobs here we've got it
zoomed in we can clean that by turning
it black and white and getting rid of
small components and that gives us a
simplified version and then we have to
deal with the fact that they're touching
this is two blobs not one so the
solution that I came up with was to look
at the distance from the edge so points
near the edge of a short distance and
points in the middle of a high distance
and if you show that as a color you end
up with this sort of what's called a
distance transform of the image and now
we're able to start picking up this set
of points you can see there's different
Peaks there's a slightly higher away
from any points that they touch so we
pick out the maximum of those we now
have countable points even though the
original was quite fuzzy messy and
touched other points so if you put that
into a little blob of code here to do
that in an automated way so I needed to
have loaded the image first of all to
apply that to the entire image then we
can identify automatically the things
that we want to count little crosses on
them in this case to identify that
position and you can see across the
image as a whole it's done a pretty good
job of picking those things out and now
we move to statistics and we can start
doing things like saying or what's the
average density so here if I just rotate
this plot around you have depth going
from the top of the image to the bottom
and height is the number of particles in
that area of the image so you can see
already a couple of insight so that they
get reaching a fairly because
depths mostly getting to a certain
similar depth but the density is kind of
around the edges of the target zone not
in the middle okay what else can we do
with computation well another thing we
can do is to inject context the very
often data is not very meaningful to us
as humans because we're not really
geared at looking at data and the
classical the statistics approach to
data handling is to reduce the data into
something that human brains can handle
which is why we look at numbers like the
mean and the standard deviation because
that's a way of reducing all that mess
and complexity of a data set down to two
numbers and we can handle two numbers
but there's other ways to make data more
understandable and a key one of those is
to is as I say to inject additional
context so here's a dataset that I
looked at a while ago I just refresh
this today with the very latest data I'm
speaking to you from the United Kingdom
where wool from this European
headquarters are and here we run a
system of the local authorities raise
the hygiene of every place that serves
food in the country so here's some
hygiene ratings for these are all places
in Oxford around the corner from where I
am here and there's a restaurant called
the 1738 cafe and it's got a perfect
rating these are zero to five rating so
it's perfectly clean food and somewhere
further down the list we've got a crop
list which is a three out of five which
is I think your need of improvement
but you know this thousands of thousands
of 8-point says 1334 just for this for
the Oxford City alone and there's tens
of hundreds of thousands of costs the
United Kingdom as a whole how can you
get a sense of what's going on well one
thing is to bring in other information
that's outside of this data set and the
obvious one here is to bring in things
like mapping information so now I can
take that data set and I can throw all
of those points into a map of Oxford and
you can immediately see where the food
supplies places are centred that they
they are lots and the city centers you
would expect as a tourist attraction but
Oxford is there's a lot heading up this
road and this area of town and then
scatter through the the places that
people live over to the east of Oxford
but then we're laying competition on top
of that we can start pulling out some
interesting
Insights here's the same map again but
looking at what the typical trends are
and now you get the kind of interesting
insights that the lowest high team on
average is in this area called Cowley
Road well that's where all the students
live so there's a lot of students
accommodation and and student flats
around this area and all the best high
genes up in this North Area well that's
where the all the rich people live
that's the million pound house district
of the of the city and there's a
genuinely low area somewhere around the
station well a lot of people are passing
through transiently actually if you want
to go sightseeing in the UK here's the
the overall trend across the country and
generally you can see if you know you're
British geography that the these are
urban centres that have the lowest food
hygiene that out on the downloads of the
four out of five on average whereas some
of the more rural areas are averaging
closer to five out of five and that made
me think well we can inject some more
contacts here this was a hypothesis that
I was seeing this urban band across the
middle of the country and across the the
west of the country what if we actually
do that point-by-point so just before I
came on there's an hour ago I ran this I
looked at every point and I said let's
look up the population of the city that
that point is in and you get this
interesting trend that I wasn't
expecting it does the hygiene does go
down as the population of towns it
increases but actually it goes down
pretty rapidly for small places from
thousand person villages down to about
10,000 persons small town and then it
seems to improve a bit as you go into
the cities who knows what that means but
it's insightly you can only get by
pulling in external data like Maps like
populations if you're looking at things
like the accidents example I don't have
time for comparing to weather on the day
and things like that and that's why what
one of the things that we do at Wolfram
is to kind automate as much as possible
about being external dating and we have
thousands of data sets from where
earthquakes our share prices all of
these kinds of things are built into the
language so that you can bring in the
context in comparison against the data
that you bring to the table ok another
thing for computation to bring us
another thing we can do is we can use
to twist data around and think about
things from different viewpoints so I've
got a fairly simple example but this one
does come from from an external
organization that I dealt with I met the
guys who owned the Bloodhound project
and they're trying to make a supersonic
car so they trying to make a car that me
is going to a thousand miles an hour and
their previous car was supersonic and
this was some data they gave me they
gave me about 50 channels of telemetry
from this supersonic car and said see
what you can make of this just as a kind
of disgust discussion point so here's
two data streams that came off the car
this is the the RPM of the front right
wheel it's a proxy for the speed of the
vehicle it's not strictly the speed
because when you go really fast sand
starts behaving like a liquid and the
thing starts the car is a bit more like
a boat but as the rough rocks here tells
us the velocity of the vehicle and the
dots are the front right suspension load
how much weight the suspension was
taking on that wheel so it's you know
you can see the car got faster and the
suspension jiggled around a bit more in
the middle of the run but it's not
deeply insightful but just pleasing
exactly the same data streams and
changing the viewpoints we can get some
different insights out so I hitting with
a little bit of basic calculus so here's
the velocity obviously the first
derivative is the acceleration and you
start seeing that the acceleration it's
not perceptible from the curve but
actually goes up in steps so we we get a
step wise improvement acceleration step
by step wise then it's at this high
acceleration and then we get this curve
drop to zero and then it's massive
stepwise negative change in acceleration
and actually context is what makes this
make sense if we throw on the throttle
position you can actually see that the
driver or pilot I don't know what he
describes himself as on there on a
supersonic car but so he's easing the
acceleration steps seeing how the car
responds before he finally at at about
three and a half thousand trying stamps
into this goes to full throttle and puts
the jet engine to maximum and there I'm
guessing that this is air resistance
building up it's still at full throttle
but the air resistance gets to the point
where it's no longer getting any faster
he takes his foot off the accelerator
and air resistance now becomes
effectively a massive windbreak
the other dimension was a little bit
trickier there I had to think about this
thing from war for a signal processing
point of view that we've got an
amplitude but actually what's
interesting here is frequency so we're
just switching the viewpoint here into a
frequency space this is time along the
bottom frequency up the side and the
brightness is the amount of intensity
you sell you see two really interesting
features pop out here and here but
there's a sudden spike in high frequency
and then it drops down again and a
sudden height spike in high frequency
and then it drops down again and then
you get this very strong spike at the
end and I think I couldn't make sense of
this but the engineers immediately said
they got excited and said we've never
seen this before what you're seeing here
is the moment the top edge of the wheel
goes supersonic because the top edge is
going for twice as fast as the bottom
edge then the car is a hole that is
traveling forwards while because well
the bottom the wheels are going
backwards and so even though this wasn't
a supersonic run we're getting a shock
wave forming as it enters and exits the
sound barrier on the top edge of the
wheel and this is the brakes being
applied at the end after the parachutes
deployed so so many features pop out
that if you look at the data yes you can
see there's something going on here but
it's it's becomes much more subtle and
you certainly don't see B the later one
very easily but by switching the
viewpoints we can we can pull out new
insights so another thing we can do with
computation is to inject completely new
viewpoints rather than simply switching
things around we can just change the way
that we the way we conceptualize data
and bring in computations from fields
that you never thought applied in that
area and I've got a simple example that
I did with a customer that to me was
quite quite a fun some use of out of
scope computation so challenge was the
customer had these portfolio
correlations so what this is is that if
you want a if you want to reduce risk in
a portfolio you don't buy all shares
that move in the same direction at once
because you either make a lot of money
or you lose a lot of money and if you
want stability you want to mix things up
a bit that don't all move in the same
direction to give us some stability so
this is just a statistical made table of
the correlation
that is a thx is as he would expect
perfectly correlated with itself but has
a slight anti correlation with P FBX and
his question for us was these numbers
are important but they're really hard to
get your head around the big table of
numbers he said can you make this into a
nice grid of colors so we did that we
said directly his visualization of it
and maybe we can make it slightly better
by allowing you to set some threshold
and just pick out those of the meeting
at threshold but there's still no kind
of sense of structure there's no real
insight it just allows you to hone in on
the the key values quicker so we decided
to give him a new insight and we took an
idea from from geology at the folk I
first saw this with dolphin populations
which was to measure which dolphins hung
out with each other but then to try and
figure out what the families are from
the collections of these pairings so by
considering these things as pairings we
can now pull out those that met the high
threshold and build the families of the
pairings so here we've got a pairing
that says this BIOS chair is highly
correlated to Andy and Andy is highly
correlated to WB MD but collectively
they start forming this family even
though BIOS isn't highly correlated to
SR CL when you start looking at the
relationships they're only sort of four
or three relationships away from each
other and because of the common
strengths across there we end up with
this family forming and if we change the
correlation we can see different
families now as is often the way with
with good data science it doesn't
necessarily provide you answers it's
sort of a classical statistics things to
say here's the answer I want and now I'm
going to measure it
modern based science is very much often
about pulling out insights that are
questions for you as a human to then
consider what is it
that these things all have in common
that means they move as family maybe
it's something very obvious like they're
all energy stocks and these are all
building stocks and these all banking
stocks but maybe there's something more
subtle going on that that causes this
movement correlation between the assets
and only by pulling them out and then
highlighting them to you are you able to
do the more human task of using
intelligence to try and answer
answer the sort of broader softer
questions that hard data science can
provoke and cross in the end one of the
things that we're trying to do with
competition is to separate that signal
from noise that's in the data data is
filled with signals but it's also filled
with noise and we have to separate those
so I wanted to show one that's really
quite a long way from what you think of
as classical data science and is and it
popped into my head that this was a good
example when I was thinking signal from
noise because here is actually literally
a noise with the signal in it so
hopefully that comes across the seminar
software and it's the sound of a car
going past this thingy as it goes past
so the sound though is is all kinds of
frequencies and the engine noise and
there's a bit of road noise in there as
well but actually a signal we want or
the signal is interesting here is a
speeding ticket
because if we pick through this and look
at things like the frequencies and so
here's how the frequency shift get
through that add those together and make
an average we get an average frequency
shift we do some something you wouldn't
think of more as physics modeling we can
look up to the formula for Doppler shift
and this is that get straight out of
Wikipedia this is the way sound is
shifted by by being coming from a moving
source we can then fit that to the
result and end up with the parameter
estimates so you think of that more is
modeling but here I'm taking data and
I'm pulling out insights that's data
science from my book
so here's the final insight the velocity
here is nineteen point four seven meters
a second so about 30 40 miles an hour so
in an urban area that would be a
speeding ticket and indirect we also end
up finding out that the vehicle came
within four point seven meters of the
observer so not too close that the the
microphone was was set well back from
the road
as the vehicle went past but that's all
buried in that sound and when you start
asking these questions about I've got
this data set of all these 30-40
measurements of some behavior of my
customers or behavior of some
engineering device I've built the
insights were often not just the well
what's the biggest of this parameter
what's the smallest of that parameter
what's the average of this parameter
the insights are often much more subtle
and you have to have these creative
questions of what could be hidden there
and then used a full power of
computation to extract those out so if
they science is more than just counting
why is it the most eight science in
practice in the wild is various forms of
just counting and doing statistics and
there's two answers that one is
conversation can be difficult and the
other is that you better know what's
possible now the second ones is really
an educational question that knowing
that the what all of the possibilities
of competition out there are and the
kind of tool sets available is something
now educational system has to address
and I had lots to say about that but
that's a subject for another day so I'm
gonna address this issue of the
difficulty of computation and really
that's something that we've been
focusing on for a long time and the
answer to all of that is automation but
is automation in a higher level than
then software typically targets because
technical software typically automates
the application of an algorithm but what
we want to do is always to automate the
knowledge required to apply the
algorithm so sort of higher level I'm
gonna skip through this example quickly
because I'm over running time and
because Etienne is going to go through
this how things like casts apply and
and predict work much better than I wore
but I'm just going to show a quick
example here to make really one one
point so this is a classic data set
these passengers of the Titanic this
passenger was the first class 29 year
old female and she survived and we've
got thirteen hundred and nine data
points and I want to do some machine
learning to try and predict what would
happen if I were to travel on the
Titanic so I'm asking you to classify
the data you'll notice here I'm not
having to say anything more I just say
classify and it's automating as much as
possible it figured out that it's
nominal numerical nominal category
nominal numerical nominal that the
classes are died has survived and most
importantly out of about eight or ten
different algorithms is decided for
itself which I'll wouldn't use and then
it's applied the algorithm so it's come
up with a decision tree in this case is
decided it's most appropriate and then
using that decision tree I can make my
prediction alpha I guess I've
all this over this example what would
happen to me on on the Titanic well once
you have that level of automation you
can take that as broadly as possible so
where it's an automated the data types
well that automation can really board so
if I take a completely different example
and do kind of this computer vision
example and take photos and say are
these nighttime or daytime photos well
if you look at it I'm doing exactly the
same thing I'm just saying what the task
is classify and the input data and the
output class the fact that they're
photographs in this case and the fact
that in this case it's going to use
logistic regression over some key
features well that doesn't matter to me
that's for when things get difficult or
when I'm more of an experts but as a
beginner I can just go in there and say
classify and automation does as much as
possible and you can see here that it's
done a reasonable job for three
nine-time ones it's got right the three
daytime ones it's got two out of three
by not too bad it's got this one a bit
longer than if the yellow is making it
look like a neon light or the dark cars
looking like nighttime but something's
confused in there now I'm sort of
alluded to this earlier that one of the
things we want they decides to do is to
actually automate the insights so
sometimes we simply don't know what
we're looking for and and really that's
where machine learning is extremely
strong where your data which but
understanding poor and you don't know
what the model is you wanted to suggest
models but sometimes even suggest things
that that that that you might want to
look at as a model so I just show a
couple of examples of this quickly I'm
gonna also do a little google image
search here so let's do something like
pretty villages so I'm just at this
stage just doing a Google search for
images that match that phrase pretty
villages and if Google is going to be
nice and responsive for me oops I didn't
want to show the code there that's the
code by in the example but that's not
the point here right so what's a good
one here this looks a bit like a local
village to me that looks very
Oxfordshire to me so if I click on this
image I'm going to have a machine
learning classify use experience of
photos it doesn't know anything about
the metadata to say where does it look
like in the world that it's and it's and
I picked a good one here because it's
has basically said here's Oxford it's it
is very locals we actually a bit further
out it thinks it's closer to Crystal our
offices over here but it looks very much
like this part of the world whereas if I
click on let's see this one looks very
uh neglige don't really go in for big
tarik towers very much here and yet
things that looks like um let's see
Geneva over here that looks like France
by yes limo so we're in France recognize
that now what's the model for that
that's beyond me as a human I would I
would look at this and in fact you're
steered in the same way in an
experiential way so those kind of
insights of what are the features well
we need to get that from machine
learning but we have that changes the
way we work with computers we have to be
treating computers like a member of the
team rather than as a slave so in the
old days you wrote an algorithm and you
said run the code just like I guess in
the 50s you've had employees in you
would say go and make me a cup of tea
and do it this way now we expect
employees to have a bit of insight of
their own well our supervision becomes a
slightly more hands-off so the typical
mode here for for supervising is just in
people to find evidence that is useful
so I'm going to show kind of how that
might work in practice I'm gonna let's
put this into a watch mode here I'm
gonna grab a screen shot and I'm gonna
teach it rock-paper-scissors not how to
play just what they look like so I'm
gonna pick rock here and capture some
images so I'm labeling this I'm giving
it supervision to tell it what these
things look like we're gonna about ten
of each so that's some papers and now we
need to show what scissors looks like
the universal symbols for what paper
scissors and we've got a bunch of those
let's do some training and we will ask
you to use some to inject the inside of
what is it that makes a rock paper and
scissors and it's correctly said
scissors which you'd seen that one
before but let's have it what sonic
doesn't see now so those are scissors
rock paper scissors and it's doing a
fairly good job of recognizing what I'm
doing from those thirty odd images that
I've given it so our job becomes more of
a teacher than than a controller when
you enter the machine learning space
and sometimes we don't even give it any
guidance what we want to do is to have
it suggest things that we might want to
think about so now that sort of paradigm
of that is the completely unsupervised
learning and I have one fun example to
show you which is a slightly contrived
example because I know the result here
but here's some pictures of dogs I took
this from the Stanford dogs database you
can download it's got about a hundred
breeds of dog I've just taken three
breeds here and about twenty images of
each and these two hours basset hounds
and wolf hounds but I'm not giving it
any labels these are just pictures I'm
not even telling it that they're dogs
I just wanted to examine that data and
break them up into things that look
similar and things that look different
and it's up to the computer to try and
figure out what those features might be
so here's the visualization is just come
up with and it's plotted this other kind
of two dimensional feature space where
and you can see you know in this case
the clustering is very obvious to us as
humans these it's clustered into the
breeds of the dog so we got all the two
hours of form to cluster over here all
the Wolfhounds over here and all the
basset hounds over here and then we've
got some in the middle that that you
know this is a little bit unclear I
think I can't even tell looking at it it
looks like you might be holding two
hours but it's the least two hour like
it's the most Basset like two hour and
this Basset is getting a bit close to
the two hours it's the most to our like
Basset I guess and but what is done here
is it's put them into the groups it says
I think maybe these things have
something in common now in this case
it's very obvious partly because of the
examples that I've chosen and partly
because we as humans do a very similar
thing very well we sort of see visual
similarities very quickly but if we did
something that was a little bit more
abstract they I took I played exactly
the same kind of idea to the share price
movements on a set of shares beginning
with the letter M and we'd also same
kind of clustering going on here but
this time because I don't have any real
insight I don't know these things
off something and I don't see breeds of
share and it's not obvious what the
thing is that is
in the cluster you might speculate that
at this end of the plot we've got shares
that went up during the period is they
send shares that went down but maybe
there are other features what makes
these four shares MSI MSG and MS bf so
similar I don't know but there's
something in the data there that make
that prompts me with the question of the
machine learning suggests there's some
similarity between these go away and
think about what they might have in
common maybe they all share the same the
same PR agency or something and have all
been putting out the right press
releases at the right times or maybe
they have something else in common or
they're all energy stocks it's the
answer isn't there without further
investigation but that insides of
automated machine learning to tell me
what I might look at is it's quite a
high-level interaction with the data I'm
in all over on time so I'm going to just
talk about one aspect here which is
automation goes beyond just computation
the whole workflow of data science has
to be automated so if you think what the
workflow is you've got this sort of data
capturing step or a date or importing
step then there's this of computation
step there might be a visualization step
there may be a loop that goes back round
as you get insights and you direct more
computation then there might be a
reporting step where you're trying to
produce something that's narrative to
read for somebody else so there might be
a deployment step of delivering that in
a way that somebody can interact with
your insights or that can drive some
other part of the machinery of your
organization
and what we're after is to automate that
whole workflow I'm just going to pick
out one part of it that's outside the
computation here which is the deployment
and I'm just gonna pick out one aspect
of that that kind of non human part just
to show the kind of level of automation
that that we can bring to bear here this
was the Titanic classify the day I made
earlier in the talk I can deploy that
thing so that it can be computed farmer
database or from a website or a mobile
app and to do that I want to have some
kind of restful api service well we have
a symbolic representation of all the
machine learning of all of the
programming language of Met
language of all of the visualizations so
all we have to is copy that on to it
onto a cloud server that can run the
Wolfram language and it can be run from
there so by wrapping this thing with a
little bit of dressing to say I want an
API where I'm going to pass three
parameters in and it's what it's going
to do with it is to run there our
classifier that we built now I'll have
to say it's copy that's a server with
cloud deploy and run listing there's all
bit of extra information like what
permissions it has so that everyone in
the world can see it
I might want to set that to private to
some secret key if it's going to empower
some mobile app that I'm selling but
here I'm making it public and that's all
there was to the whole deployment cycle
if I open up a web browser now you'll
see that on this address that didn't
exist more than a few seconds ago we've
now we're now serving up in this case a
failure mode this is a bunch of Jason
coming back saying I haven't provided
the parameters so this is serving live
computation offer restful service in a
machine readable JSON format and then it
becomes that step of well how do we
embed that into something else we can
use templates to say here's the Java
that I would need to embed into a java
application to make a web services call
or I could call it from some other
application that knows how to access
these services and so for example we
have a tool that you can plug into Excel
that allows me to make Excel
spreadsheets and I'll do machine
learning so here I'm running the same
machine learning classifier off that
address and it's it's calculating
machine learning from something as
low-tech as Excel and the way it does it
is this final cell makes a reference to
the Wolfram API to the address the visor
I delivered it to with which parameters
to pass and that corresponds directly to
this address that I served it on so in
one line of code little more than the
line that it took me to do the
classification I've delivered and
deployed and set up for external access
this this machine learning and
ultimately the more you can deploy your
machine learning the more people you can
use it the the more bang you get out of
the work that you've done so I wanted to
leave a few minutes I've got five
minutes to take some questions so why
you think about typing some question
into the questions panel over on the
side of the chat session now to make a
quick closing remark about to sum this
up but when you think about data science
call in your mind to the tool set
because it is absolutely huge and it
isn't necessarily within the domain
networking you might be working in in
biological sciences and doing date signs
in that well maybe there were thick
tools that were developed for
engineering or for finance or or human
resource management that can be brought
to bear and automation makes them
accessible to you because the concepts
of what they do is usually a lot easier
to read up on quickly than the details
of being an expert in knowing which
parameter is optimal for some particular
circumstances and whether you should use
this statistical test or that one
automation makes them accessible to on a
conceptual level by getting rid of all
of that difficult detail of doing the
computation so you're left to focus on
just the question you're asking and that
lets you shift the the process on to on
to asking the right questions and
letting the data science the computation
produce the kind of riches insights you
can from that so there are some
questions coming in so one is from
Mohsen they're interested in
multilingual sentiment analysis so we do
have support for semantic text in a
multilingual space so we we know about
things like dictionaries of different
languages and and the character sets the
relevant for which language and and
translations between languages so you
know there's a couple of protists you
could take on this you could use also
translation to put things into English
and use the built-in English classifier
so it's fine to take sentiment but
ultimately what you need to do is to
generate training data and and retrain
the classifier to use or an appropriate
classifier to use the training data if
you have so if you can find some source
data that I can tell from your name
what language you're you're looking at
but if you can find source basically in
your language they can be labeled as
positive or negative then then you just
simply run sort of a classify type
command as I did earlier on in order to
learn what it is that are the words of
your language that indicate positive or
negative Ness and then and then just use
it the same way that I have with the
built in one that I showed earlier how
[Music]
okay so in deploying a model to the
cloud can it be password-protected
yes so so actually if I go back to the
example I showed here the permission
structure here allows me to to control
to individual named users to a there's a
user groups mechanism I can set things
to be public but you have to be logged
in to access them there is a design for
rich mechanism for permissions that
would allow you to say you know
accessible only from from French IP
addresses after midday from Firefox
browser kind of thing but none of that's
been implemented yet so if you wanted to
have which permissions like time of day
permissions you would have to put that
into the function that runs but the
permission structure allows you to
control users and groups and whether or
not they can access whether they can
call that the the service or not and the
same goes true for things like if I do a
forum page for example which is I think
I need to probably turn up one of these
options here if I set this up as a forum
this is now meant for human use and I
can type in that I in first class 21
year old female and click Submit and run
it as a human so this page here has the
same permission structure that I had
before I can set that to be private to
named individuals
okay so Moses clarified that the
language is Arabic I will say that there
was a slight problem with Arabic which
is nothing I don't think is problematic
at all from the machine learning point
you Etienne can comment in at the end of
his talk perhaps we do have we don't
have full support for display of Arabic
within the wulfing language but we're
actually doing a project right now we're
doing a budget with Egypt to deploy lots
of educational material for their
learning system and so we're we're
improving the Arabic rendering support
for the web first and also the notebooks
second which said actually improve over
the coming year is wolf language being
used in industry by data science yes so
probably the best thing is to have a
look at our website where there's a
bunch of user stories certainly so one
of the things I do for the companies I
run a technical services group in Europe
and we do the custom coding so sales
guys just sell licenses of wolf language
but we take customer problems and code
them up and actually by far the majority
of my work is in one form another data
science problems sort of you know
usually in half of that is people who
are interested in getting into AI and
wanting to use machine learning but
certainly we're not we're not the only
ones doing that using Wolfram language
there's plenty of people where we
provide the technology and they don't
need our help at all and just get on
with it so the court amount whether
companies used sentiments analysis
within the organization to understand
data flow - it's a fine question I don't
have a good example of that that I can
think of off the top of my head I had
discussions with an organization about
using that for HR to try and spot
whether people were unhappy and likely
to leave but we never actually did do
that project so it's certainly it's a
feasible thing I've thought about but I
don't know any specific examples if I
need training off offline well can I put
the model in the cloud yes so so the
object becomes
back from the training Frank that's
exactly what I did here was this Titanic
survival I trained locally and I could
do that locally accelerate by GPU but
then I deployed it to the cloud you can
run it the other way around as well you
can have the cloud do the training and
you could deploy it for example to a
Raspberry Pi so we have a reversion of
the wulfing language that that the one
that can run on the grass we fire has
very underpowered it's a five dollar
computer so it you wouldn't want to do
your training on that unless you really
had to but it can run it perfectly
adequately so once you've got these
models they're portable between every
version of the Wolfram language a
question about connection with our we
have a one directional connection with
our that allows us to call our to call
our libraries that are specialists in
areas that we haven't covered to call
from our two so access warm language
capabilities you'd have to probably use
the Wolfram script to use the kind of
scripting level at the operating system
of the language so you can run out of a
tree sort of bash type scripts off
Wolfram language I would love to go on
this about four or five questions that
maybe I will stay and answer through the
chat system to those of you had time but
if I speak any longer
I will encroach on etienne store which
promises to be very interesting so
please stay for that and I will hand off
to Etienne to show how some of this
magic happens inside the language thank
you very much thank you John I was great
to see you navigating the all those
examples we're gonna go ahead and push a
second poll question out as we
transition to a TN our next speaker and
I can yep here it comes so here's a poll
question asking about your use of
machine learning and we're interested to
see in what areas you in the audience
are making use of machine learning in
your work now if you are
alright ok so I see that Alf the person
use traditional methods which is good
that's what we're going to talk about in
this talk
then there's almost 40% do not use
machine learning so that's that's I mean
actually that not that surprising but
but I guess hopefully this talk might
give some an engine stop before some
insight about how they can use machine
learning and 25% that use deep learning
okay
well that's interesting results that
will try to take into account during
during my talk and so I'm going to be to
go more into details
compared to adjourned each and it kind
of a broad overview about what that
Athens is I'm going to talk about more
of a specific part which is a modeling
part okay so I'm going to talk to a more
restricted part which is about the
modeling and and about some recent
before that we've done to automatize
this modeling part so so here's just one
example of what you could do with the
automated data scientist I mean as you
saw before in John's talk there's many
other tasks that you can do with the
science but I think it's a typical task
because it involves predicting something
and in order to get a result so here the
idea is you have a let's say a baker
that there's a bunch of data that is
recorded in his bakery and wants to plug
data sort of automatic data scientist
software on database and start asking
questions to it and it could for example
ask how many quests aren't going to sell
next Sunday and the computer will look
at the recorded data and possibly all
the factors such as the weather at the
time for the data that have been
acquired and Unser there is a 90% chance
that between 62 and 67 question will be
sold so that's that's a bit as a dream
and and again this is just one task and
there are many many other tasks and of
course this involves so this but
kela example involves many many many
things such as understanding humans
understanding the data that isn't a
bakery because the human didn't gave any
you don't tell anything about the data
access external data for example to know
about the past weather and the automatic
modeling part which is building a model
I can predict the number of croissant
that would be sold according to all the
features and of course communicating the
result back and so what I'm going to
talk today is about this automatic
modeling part which actually under the
hood also include a bit of data
understanding and a bit of accessing
external data okay so so we have a few
automated machine learning functions in
the language that we started to
implement this version 10
they are very task-oriented function so
you saw example John gave a few example
of these functions for example for
classifications you will just give a
bunch of data to a function called
classify and we'll return a classifier
for aggression is a function called
predict that work the same way or
clustering a function called find
clusters and there's some other other
parts and what automated in in these
functions so this function we need to
understand the type of the data for
example is this data text is the
categorical variable of a numerical
variable think like that it needs to
figure out how to pre-process this data
then it also need to figure out how
there are some smart in a way good
features to extract from this data for
example if it's an image it might make
sense to run a neural network on it
there has been pre trained let's say to
classify images and and extract some
features with this neural network that
will be semantically rich features you
can also perform feature augmentation
that's that's similar as the weather
example that I gave here if you can or
let's say there's a city that is in the
data in data set maybe we want to
augment the data by adding the popular
one of the city or the country media
city is because that might help to model
and answer the question and and final
parts that is automated he is to select
the best model and the best hyper
parameters this is usually these
parameters that are tuned by hand in
opposition to the parameters that are
learned by the by the learning algorithm
and also we want this function to be
robust to dirty data for example if
there's some missing values in the
training data I wanted to work if
there's a missing values in the
evaluation data as well wanted to work
and will also want the user to have
control over what's happening through
some lower level specification but I'm
low level education but I'm not going to
talk much about about them they're a bit
boring but also through high level user
specification for example you might want
to say oh I want a classifier but I want
it to be small in memory because you
know I want to deploy it on an embedded
device later for example so you could do
that with with the option performance
goal and set it to memory or you can say
alright I have four minutes to try this
model so I want you to use four minutes
and and there's a function option that
is called time goal to to do that that's
a bit the idea of this this function let
me show you an example so the simplest
example possible we're going to use a
function classify so here you see given
a training set that's for example in
this training set each example is
composed of an input and an output and
the goal is to predict the output which
is a class here can be a or b asking for
the input which in this case is a
numerical value so let's evaluate this
code and it returns a classifier
function and then we can start using it
for example I will ask okay one was a
two was a so one point six was probably
a and that's that the case but we can
also ask for the probabilities like how
certain are you that one
a and in that case it's actually
overconfident that it's a which mean
that it's yeah actually in a way it's a
bit wrong because it's too overconfident
but that's because the training set is
very very small in practice you have
larger training set and the
probabilities make make more sense
there's a very similar function that is
predict which is not about writing a
class but predicting numerical values so
let's do and something like that and
this time it returns a predictive
function that you can use in the same
way so okay 1 1 1 point 3 2 was 4 point
5 so let's try 1 point 6 again and it
should be probably something between 1
point 3 and 4 point 5 actually it's
funny it's more than that ok and and you
can ask again for the probabilities but
it's time this time sits it is numerical
value you will ask for the distribution
so you can see that it's not very
confident about it so it's 4.6 but plus
minus 2.8 kind of so it's a normal
distribution okay so that's our I would
say the main automatic automated machine
learning functions we have which by the
way are in the in the domain of our
supervised learning that's probably the
one that I used most and I'm going to
talk more about this one because it's
the one I think we've perfected the most
and and later I will mention the other
functions that we have and the other
function that we are developing right
now which I hope they have the right to
speak about but that should be fine ok
so let's do a image classification
example so you already saw examples into
implantation so let's be quick about it
I will spend more time about using you
know analysis tools to understand how
good is a classifier so I'm going to
just create image from the web I never
done that before but let's let's let's
scrape some superheroes
just so the avenger' today's ago and so
okay look list
Superman let's put what Batman
Iron Man Wonder Woman okay let's try
this so I'm going to square 40 images
from the web for each query and so there
must be 160 images so actually I'm going
to put let's say 20 in the training set
and the last 40 in the test set so this
is will be the split that is very
classic to do when you're trying to
mention the only model to reserve some
data in a test set in order to test the
performance better actually I can I can
look show you what the training that I
look like okay so here we go we have
this tag data about bunch of superheroes
and
and let's run classify and here I will
say we have time so you know it's not me
imagine taking your time and just give
the best classifier that you can so I
specify that by performance goal quality
and actually let me just name it it's
going to be easier to play with
afterwards so it's people sings data
actually the processing involves what I
was talking before a neural network that
extracts features that are specialized
for for images and that's why we can
train is that small amount of images
like normally if you start from scratch
training with 40 image by class is
impossible but because we have this
semantic features it would be much
easier okay so so it's trained good
actually we can have a look you know
since why not can I look inside to see
what it's doing a little bit and and you
can see that it's okay as some missing
attention thing there's some image
confirmation and this is the is a neural
network that extract the features and
anyway you can see also a bunch of
information about what happened into the
automation but that's that's not
supposed to be excessive of the user but
you can still do it by just looking
inside the classifier if you're
interested alright let's let's let's try
it so I'm going to grab let's say the
first three example of the test set and
let's try it so I never try that one but
let's see
I earn money great okay we can ask all
the probabilities and what's very
convinced it's Iron Man it's actually a
bit surprising let's look at the others
it's quite convinced as well okay I mean
this this makes makes more sense okay it
seems to be a pretty pretty good
classifier probably the test was not
that hard so let's let's measure things
a bit more
you know in a better way I'm going to
use classifier measurements function why
I put the classifier at the first
argument and the test set at the second
argument and this returns a classifier
measurement object that then I can use
to query values properties and actually
the first property that I should just
ask is just a report just a report and
the report says there was 40 test
examples the accuracy was 87 point 5 but
plus or minus 5% because you know the
other side of the test set a simple
baseline would be 30% of accuracy so
you're much better okay you have some
other information also the time it takes
to evaluate a single example the speed
it takes 28 many examples and a
confusion matrix actually let's let's
look at the judge the confusion metric
so I'm going to type oops confusion
matrix so matrix plots sorry and here we
go so that's that's so so you can see
here number of test example of a given
class but I've been classified another
class so this 12 Ironman are correctly
classified so okay Ironman is kind of
perfect so that's probably why we get
this good result but there is a Superman
misclassified as Batman so let's have a
look at this one so I will say examples
and I will say let me actually I think
that is exchanges and texts recently so
a Superman classifier
as Batman here you go that's a for some
reason this Superman's classified Batman
I guess it has a bit of a dark suit on
this one anyway that that's the sort of
tools you can use to analyze your
classifier and analyze your test set
actually but sometimes you'll figure out
that oh actually it was a Batman yeah
so that's pretty pretty useful tools
okay
let's continue so now we'll just trust
what changed in the latest version so
something you already saw with this
training progress panel when when you
trained that that should progress bar
current values of values by this metric
the learning curve the stop button to
actually let me show you on a very
classic that I said what it looks like
and and something that lasts a bit
longer than actually I could I could set
a time goal you know what I'm gonna time
go on 60 seconds so this is going to
train for six together and we'll have
the time to appreciate the training
panel so we can see time elapsed the
current best method and here is a
learning curve so basically it's the
system's system trains very small on
values data sets length and you can see
that for data set of lengths here it's
300 the best model as this lost value
you can also have the equivalent in
accuracy so you can see how giving
larger data set leads to higher accuracy
and here you can see kind of the
learning curve of all the algorithms or
all the models sorry that are tested so
currently it's in that the nearest
neighbor is kind of leading logistic is
not far away run on forests is not so
great
okay and out random push the tree seems
to have taking the lead so okay let's
stop it so you have also have a stop
button which allows you to stop the
computation at any time and returns the
best classifier so far so I guess okay
it shows granny boosted tree in that
case
that's at this training progress panel
which you can actually control with with
you know training progress reporting
option so if I say training progress
let's say reporting now and it won't
show anything or if I say print which is
useful when you work in a terminal it
will just you know print the values
values instead of its cancel that
instead of showing the panel okay and
another thing that changed is this
classifier information panel so this is
once the model is trained you can do
classifier information of the classifier
and you have this panel that shows you
okay the input iPod image then class
method is Grandma's III actually you
mouse over the method it can tell you
the options that are you so kind of
hyper parameters that have been used to
train these this model and you can see
list of this parameter in the
documentation so if I go to grade and
gustatory for example which is probably
one that has the most number of a
parameter we have a documentation page I
kind of explain what this is and and
give the list of the other parameters
that you can set because you can also
specify the method and specify let's say
with this sort of of syntax let's say
max depth is two or three that will be
the syntax for you to specify these
other parameters which we'll just call
options in that context okay and then
you can tell you okay if I use values
information and you can also have a look
at the learning curve which in a way
because it's already estimating accuracy
and loss and
evaluation time by traveling speed
transfer memory you don't necessarily
need to use classifier measurements
anymore however when you want to go
deeper such as analyzing confusion
matrix and so on classifier measurements
it's still very useful for these things
ok so that's that's kind of what was new
in there in the last versions of the
language and you can do very quickly
although because I think it's might not
be interesting for everyone but just
what's going on of the wood under the
hood so one thing that is happening is
we have some automatic processing so one
part is understanding automatically the
data so here is a function it's it's an
internal function you don't need to know
about it but for the one that our a bit
curious that will kind of understand the
type of data automatically and then you
can create pipelines of publishing such
as standardize everything that is
numerical one hurting code of luminal
vector also merge all the vectors and
and that would kind of perform this
operation and give the pipeline and can
be used later that's what you can see if
you dig inside the writes inside the
classifier that this this is how this
one will take time okay that the sort of
things you can see when you dig inside
inside a classifier which maybe one day
we can turn this tools top-level that
would be that would be great but as you
can imagine it's a yeah that's we always
try to have really nice design for
everything with top level and and and
that's why we have to spend some time
some time and making things he then
first and when we feel they're ready you
would make them top level there's also
some some automatic conversions
happening for example if you want give
some text but the method that has been
specified once a numerical vector there
is this kind of a backup backup strategy
to convert things from a text to
numerical vector and here the path will
be too
you have a preprocessor that change in
the nominal sequence which I guess
extract words or characters and and then
there's something to calculate a tf-idf
vector from this nominal sequence so
that's a bit what's happening under the
hood another thing that is happening
it's probably the most I don't know if
it's a most important but maybe the most
interesting is how to to select the best
model and the best type of parameters
what we call the configuration and the
strategy is quite intuitive it's just to
start with the initial set of
configurations let's say 10 or 100
configurations and then perform
experiments on small data set so
basically training these configurations
on small data set so in this case there
is as small as 10 examples and over here
40 examples and then only select only
trained the most promising
configurations on larger data sets for
example here you may have 10 trained on
for the examples but only 4 trained on
200 and only one trained on a heightened
rate so that's that's a classic strategy
there's actually some some like in the
literature that there's some related
method one is called hyper band and so
ok so I guess let's look again at the
end this thing and you can see more in
real action what's happening so you see
this bit of experiment being done then
the best are tested on a lot of data set
and it's going back and forth sometimes
when it when it figures that it has time
0 I have time let's do more experiments
on smaller data sets so that's a bit of
a sneak peak of the automation
procedural there's a lot of other
details but but I don't think that's
appropriate for this webinar and but a
nice thing about this automation is that
it has nice by-product so we can see a
progress bar we can interrupt at any
time we can also say this is tango
things
and we can see the learning curves and
have as an output of the measurement and
the learning curve which I believe is
very important to decide what to do next
I feel learning curve a super important
tool to decide basically do I need more
data or not but usually the classic
question and anyway you can see there
was a blog a few months ago about about
this ok so I'm almost done there and
that's good because then left time for
questions so just to tell you there's
some other functions in the like
automatic machine learning function in
the language I must say that don't not
use yet an automation that is as
sophisticated as classify and predict so
one of our work is to I mean it's an
automation you know there's a lot of
good heuristics there but we want to
make it more based on doing experiments
and so on which literally improve by a
big fact or the automation quality and
so this function of n clusters dimension
reduction feature extraction sequence
predict and so on and many can tell you
a little bit about what's coming in the
next version but we're working hard to
do it's it's mainly functions in the
unsupervised learning domain so a
function to learn arbitrary
distributions and then basically this
function we used to do and to perform a
knowledge of the task of anomaly
detection or imputing missing values
which is called missing imputation all
denoising there's not really a name yet
generate new examples that would be
something cool as well and yeah this one
won't be for the next version that just
something that we are a bit dreaming
about to perform investment learning in
a fully automated way okay I think I'm
done here yeah just some some last
thoughts about what we want to do to
improve automation further which is to
include more pre-processing in the
automation procedure
and the combined methods I think we can
go a long way by instead of returning
just a running forest or burning pretty
tree just return an average of support
vector machine and Grandpa see tree and
whatever else performs well on the other
set and also where we are we are
thinking quite I mean we actually
already have projects to basically learn
from MIDI that I said how to learn okay
I think I'm done here and for the last
next 15 minutes I will be answering
questions so yeah don't hesitate to ask
anything on the question panel all right
so let me see what do I have
[Music]
do you support GPU machine learning like
tensorflow yes so we have a neural
network framework that works very well
on GPU it's not using tensorflow on the
backend it's using MX net which actually
arguably faster although they're pretty
similar all these frameworks are pretty
similar in terms of speed for the high
level machine learning GPU will be used
to train your networks but they probably
won't be used for for other methods like
run forests and and and so on so that's
something to keep yeah that's something
to keep in mind like don't don't
necessarily need if you just do specify
you don't necessarily need to buy a big
GPU machine it might not improve things
much okay can I just change the
parameter and methods or also modify the
actual algorithms so yes you can change
the method and you can change the
parameters I was showing before with a
granny boosted tree example so it's
documented and and you can you can set
all that up like there's a low level
access to this high level function as
well okay do you have example of this
workflow using time series okay very
good question so that's that's something
we want to one of the direction we want
to go because there's a function called
sequence predict but it's a very
specific type of time I'm sorry at the
moment it's only know me know sequences
so basically let's say a sequence of
word or sequence of characters but we
want sequence predict to to be extended
to predict arbitrary sequence sequence
of okay so time series sequence of
numerical values or vectors but also
sequence of image sequence of whatever
whatever you want so that's one of the
big thing we want to work on okay so the
GPU support is built in yes it's
completely built in no separately
license
that's one thing with a walk among
waiters you get everything
there's no no bugs no tool box okay can
you add your own model around to the
list I'm a bolero Turner
okay can you add your own model to the
list of models that automated learner
tries well that's a complicated issue
because there's a lot of processing
happening so it's hard for you as a user
to know where you model gets plugged in
so actually does it there's a hidden way
to add a new one network in a method and
but but but I don't think that's a good
design to to make that top level so I
don't think will provide besides the
fact that you can specify the method and
other parameters although we could we
could turn this automation algorithms
into a more generic tool that you can
plug whatever you want there to be any
very interesting development of this of
this work okay so what do I have
can we see the one
man classified as Superman yes the one
yeah the Wonder Woman then where are we
so we want up Wonder Woman I think it's
in no I put into words okay classify
that Superman actually there
oh yeah the three of them oh yeah well
big mistake there okay well we can see
it's quite special one there's a lego
Wonder Woman jessebella Superman and and
some more cartoonish once whereas the
typical Wonder Woman would be yeah from
the movie any typical Superman all right
that's one drive incorrectly classified
okay
oh can it be used to simplify the
of folksonomy so taxonomy based on
living data from feedback like comments
or question about blogging
okay so taxonomy so I guess it will more
of a cluster problem and and there are
they asked some some function about that
as some even yeah key called clustering
function that you can let's see yahiko
no this less weather let's go to find
clusters and probably links toward the
Yaqui called clustering function doesn't
seem to passing they tend to cluster I
mean for sure we actually worked on that
quite some time ago so so there are some
yaki call cluster function somewhere
okay maybe maybe I should go the next
question
he called clustering yeah okay yeah good
question
oh there is a regulatory function out
there going beyond supervised
can we use prediction based on
unsupervised learning for instant
prediction based on some similar metric
on the data well so it's so okay you
have clustering okay otherwise
unsupervised learning would be for all
the type of task the task could be find
the element that I most like like a sort
of nearest but but using machine
learning to kind of do nearest in a
semantic space and this will be the role
of of feature feature nearest so that's
a task you can that you can perform in a
service learning dimension reduction is
another type of task and then does this
animal detection missing imputation D
noisy but for predicting something I
would say yeah so clustering is probably
the most I mean the closest as to what
you are talking about let's see in
sequence predict the same thing as a
recurrent neural network well very
related in a sense that a recurrent
neural network is a method of sequence
predict or will be I think at the moment
I'm not sure no no recurrent RNN are not
yet into signal predict but it will be
probably the main method of sequence
predict in the future yeah very likely
lsdm or or variant of these okay let's
see let's see let's see figure at some
other that I that uh there was a
question that was how performant are the
machine learning methods how many
samples can they handle okay so very
good question so the the speed of the
methods are so let me tell you okay I
mean for let's please
in the neural network framework and the
automatic machine learning function
genuine work can handle that arbitrary
large you can you can kind of code the
function that will grab the data
somewhere and create a batch for the
neonatal to learn because a new network
doesn't look at all the data at once
it looks at data step by step and learn
in a kind of online fashion so so and
you can use that on on the big GPUs
there's really no no problem
for the automatic machine learning
functions most of it is limited by your
RAM so I would say that typically you
have sixteen gigabyte of RAM when you
start getting to model data larger than
five gigabytes
then you should start worrying a bit
about what's what will happen
yeah so that's that's a limitation of
these automatic machine learning
functions but in practice you can have I
mean if you go on Amazon you can rent a
machine that has a large amount of RAM
and you can run the machine that as a
terabytes or on so and run your your
automatic machine learning function
without trouble there there was another
question that I that I put down was I've
trouble trusting that a computer is
trying the correct set of upper
parameters that is finding the best
possible model for the task at hand are
you doing say metamodeling to figure out
the best parameters I think that
question during John talk to figure out
the best parameter and your possible to
be able to go inside in the model choice
so yeah so it's kind of answered by by
by the thing that I was showing before
you can see the learning curve about
what what has been tried you can also
look inside the classifier you can see
the result the parameters that I've been
chosen and one interest
things that if you put a large time goal
like time go two days then you can you
can look at it's a learning curve and so
on and any it will try many more other
parameters many more answers and maybe
that can help you being convinced that
it's the best model that is a that is
chosen alright let me see the some new
questions to cook well I think that's
let's see okay
exit Ian I do have a final poll question
to pose to the audience if you have
completed yep your share thank you very
much for that extended Q&A time that was
really I was really worthwhile to get
those answers out to people the the poll
we're putting out now is about your
preferred resource for learning more
about data science and machine learning
in data science so if you could give us
some feedback here this is especially
helpful for those of us on the Wolfram
you team who are helping to prepare
courses for for that purpose so I'll
give you just a second to respond to
that voted I do want to thank you for
joining us today
this does conclude the presentations we
hope you enjoyed the talks and learned
about concepts and tools you can use to
unleash the power of your data an email
will be sent to everyone in the audience
with a link to this webinar recording
and we'll also have the download links
for the presentation notebooks we look
forward to seeing you again online on
June 6th for the third and final webinar
in this series our topic will be
curating data and integrating the
Wolfram data framework you'll receive a
reminder email about this session I also
want to invite you to sign up for a
machine learning webinar that may be of
interest to a number of you it meets on
the 3rd
I see we've got those poll results up
thank you and we're very interested to
see that especially with the interactive
course that's that's move we'd like to
direction we'd like to move to in the
future with Wolfram you with videos and
exercises available so that's really
good to see that people are interested
in that let me share my screen I want
this is the machine learning webinar
series you can sign up for this from
Wolfram you and Cassidy's put that link
out for you the the topic on May 30th is
deep learning for audio analysis and
natural language processing so I think
at least one person has asked about
audio analysis and speech recognition
and so this this webinar will be of
interest to you as you exit today a
survey will appear on your screen and we
really do appreciate your feedback we
use these results to guide us and making
improvements to the Wolfram technology
stack and adding the features most
important to the user community so thank
you again for joining us
and we will hope to see you next time we
hope you have a great day